wir wollen jetzt hier sprechen im studio
mit unserem bild lei chef claus strunz
über unsere verantwortung gegenüber
diesen opfern es gab diesen diesen
hilferuf der einen hier in dieser
sendung nicht loslässt von mila die uns
sehr ins gewissen geredet hat eben und
wir alle stehen eigentlich so davon
müssen sagen ja sie hat ganz genau mit
diesen worten recht wir verantworten
diese opfer mindestens mit ja man kann
es nicht anders sagen die eskalation
dieses krieges die wir jetzt zehn führt
uns ein drittes mal in kurzer zeit vor
die naivität des westens unsere eigenen
naivität und obwohl ich mich eigentlich
nicht für eine ewigkeit anhalt würde ich
fast sagen meine naivität auch es führt
uns vor dass wir nicht vorbereitet sind
auf den undankbaren extremfall dabei
müsste verantwortungsvolle politik genau
das tun warum sage ich zum dritten mal
wir waren nicht vorbereitet auf das
hochwasser 200 tote wir waren nicht
vorbereitet auf eine pandemie wir
erinnern uns impfstoff alles mögliche
keine masken irgendwie so das bedeutet
ja wir haben gesagt na ja schon
hochwasser passiert doch nicht so ein
kleiner fluss zack reister die leute weg
niemand hat sich damit befasst was
passiert wenn das ungewöhnliche eintritt
wir haben gesagt eine pandemie die
spanische grippe also dass er ewig lange
her dass kommt er also in dem es kommt
nicht mehr kraft es die leute weg und
wir sind sozusagen schutzlos beinahe
schutzlos ausgeliefert und diskutieren
monatelang jahre lang wie wir uns
verhalten und jetzt in der
eskalationsstufe krieg und wieder stehen
wir vorbereitet da und haben noch bis in
die letzten tage hinein uns immer schön
vergegenwärtigt beim rotwein wahlweise
beim käffchen nein das macht er nicht
nein auf gar keinen fall
selbst freunde aus der ukraine haben
muss sagt nein das ist der stopp da
vielleicht diese gebiete aber da muss
man vielleicht sogar verständnis haben
jetzt nimmt er sich aber ganz
augenscheinlich die gesamte ukraine und
was ist eigentlich wenn seine kranke
idee die sowjetunion wieder herzustellen
ihn wirklich umtreibt zur sollwerte nun
kleine
nachhilfestunde haben auch gebiete
gehört die noch vielen jahren uns dran
sind und jetzt kommt der punkt des
vorbereitet sein jetzt zählen wir auf
die nato ja alle beschweren dass die
nato ich finde der nato-generalsekretär
dort eine gute figur gemacht in seiner
rede kommen vielleicht gleich noch dazu
aber jetzt beschweren alle die nato es
ist die nato der wir seit jahren unseren
beitrag schuldig bleiben wir müssten
zwei prozent unserer wirtschaftsleistung
bezahlen tun es aber nicht und wer es
verlangt hat vorausschauend und gesagt
hat wir müssen ja vorbereitet sein der
hat sich anhören müssen kriegstreiber
rechtsradikaler militär idiot jetzt
sehen wir was uns diese blauäugigkeit
und naivität eingetragen hat einen krieg
vor unserer haustür von dem noch nicht
ausgemachte sache ist dass er uns nicht
wirklich noch noch noch noch noch noch
viel näher kommt er schon nah genug
können wir in diesen stunden das ist das
was mich umtreibt sagen naja die ukraine
ist halt kein nato-partner die gehört
halt nicht zur nato und mit diesen
worten in dem moment wo wir das
aussprechen was er in den vergangenen
tagen alle wichtigen deutschen politiker
tatsächlich auch genau so gesagt haben
sagen wir ja im zweifel und genau dass
es heute passiert überlassen wir euch
überlassen wir dich mir halt deal selbst
wir helfen dir nicht können wir das
verantworten kannst du das verantworten
tu ich mir sehr schwer damit rein
rechtlich ist es völlig okay kein nato
partner ich füge etwas flapsig
unangemessen flapsigen zum pech gehabt
keine nato partner trifft kein
bündnisfall ein können wir leider nicht
helfen ich finde so kann der westen auch
nicht auf die dinge blicken wir reden
immer über solidarität solidarität in
afrika solidarität und sonstwo und wir
zeigen uns immer solidarisch jetzt
könnten uns solidarisch zeigen einem
einem eine bevölkerung gegenüber
menschen gegenüber zu dem es ganz viele
beziehungen nach deutschland private
beziehungen persönliche beziehungen da
zeigen uns aber nicht solidarisch da
sagen wir schicken 5000 helme die dann
gar nicht ankommen wir sagen aber wir
sind solidarisch am heutigen wir reden
und reden und richtig wenn ich mich dazu
rennen zu steigern beginnen muss ich
mich selber ein bisschen beherrschen
natürlich hat putin das ganze jetzt auch
so angelegt dass noch wir quasi als die
eskaliere dastehen ja also wenn wie
jetzt massiv reagieren der westen dann
wird er sagen na ja ihr habt es
eskaliert das ist schon eine komplexe
situation ist aber rein bis in jede
familie manchmal meine tochter 16 mir
vorhin geschrieben papa ich will keinen
krieg das ist so gruselig muss ich dann
da werde ich dann da eingezogen und die
bundeswehr was soll ich ihr den
antworten mach dir keine sorgen haben so
eine tolle nato die wir aber nicht
finanzieren mach dir keine sorgen wir
haben so eine tolle bundeswehr die aber
panzer hat den ich fahren und flieger
die nicht fliegen soll ich sagen mach
dir keine sorgen der herr putin wird auf
keinen fall den soldaten ins nato gebiet
setzen sollte das wirklich sagen sollte
es glaubt oder soll ich die realität
sagen und die angst machen und das ist
ja irgend jemandes verantwortung und
dass man ein zentraler gedanke es ist
die verantwortung der vorgängerregierung
wenn ich mir heute durchlese einen tweet
von annegret kramp karrenbauer die
irgendwie sagt wie wüten sie ist es das
nicht geben darf sich selbst auf sich
selbst aber auch auf ihre vorgänger ich
glaube es waren fünf unions
verteidigungsminister die eben es nicht
geschafft haben die militärausgaben in
deutschland zu erhöhen die nicht in der
lage waren sozusagen uns vorzubereiten
und da bin ich beim einem zentralen
punkt sowie corona uns vorgeführt hat
dass wir die tieren in der welt im
digitalzeitalter und faxe schicken wo
andere längst sozusagen digital
kommunizieren dass wir nicht nur die
zahlen parat haben monate und jahre
sowie uns corona unsere sünden im
zivilen vorgeführt hat führt uns die
eskalation dieser ukraine krise jetzt
unsere sünden in der verteidigung und in
der friedenspolitik vor und das ist am
ende des tages ein sehr hoher tribut für
jahrzehntelange naive politik